how about we start talking about the
capitol hill free zone
yeah sure autonomous zone jazz
autonomous zone
it sounds an awful lot like chad so
apparently apparently they've gone nuts
oh have they already yeah already well i
mean they were nuts to start
didn't they have didn't they have free
before it was it was the free zone so
it's
that jazz but no but now it's like some
people are calling it the c
like the free seattle zone the
autonomous seattle zone now it's capital
hill because it's a specific
neighborhood
oh man no i'll tell you what for the
most part
like on the surface i'm actually cool
with it yeah it's a
if if you're talking about an occupy
wall street style people banging drums
and singing songs in the street
yeah and the community is totally cool
with it i got no issue
but now you've got people showing up
with guns you've got
you've got lawlessness some dude
apparently was tagging so he got
confronted then someone pulled a gun
and then somebody was like dude we're
the police now okay we're the police now
you do what we say people are freaking
out they're like this is getting scary
because you've got a bunch of
woke crazy people saying they're the
police
apparently one of the guys is accused of
being a sex offender by some of the
other activists
it's like now you have this guy walking
around claiming to be in charge this is
what you asked for
it's true they're calling about what are
they calling them a warlord you know you
know some people are going to businesses
and and telling them they they need to
pay money
what we need to pay us money 500 no
where'd you hear that
i read an article about it what yep they
i i did read that they were forcing
businesses to quote
dis affiliate from the city yeah it was
it was from one of the business owners
he was just uh talking to them they're
like you know can i
pay in bitcoin and they're like yeah
sure sure you can pay with bitcoin
so they're he's like oh okay well what's
the thing i need to
where do i pay it and he was gonna pay
it and then they left and haven't come
back yet and he's like i don't i can't
barely even afford that
did you hear about what happened in
minneapolis that hotel i i heard a
little bit about it how they kind of
took it over a couple rooms oh they
moved over the whole place yeah and then
they posted a gofundme raised 150k
and they were like the owner has
graciously allowed us to use the
building
you know you know what really happens no
you get you get a mob of crazy people
smashing and destroying the city and
they walk in and say
it's our building look at me look at me
we are the sheraton now
and the guy goes okay yeah please please
just take it don't hurt me and then they
turn to the camera and go
he's graciously letting us use it yeah
under duress you lunatics
yeah now he's evicted everybody because
like as soon as he
as soon as things died down he's like
get out invicted 200 people and they're
like but but it's our rift
he didn't even a victim per se he just
made he cancelled the cards
so they couldn't get back into oh is
that what happened yeah
so they they were starting to complain
like well i can't get back in my room
and he's like oh i don't care
[Laughter]
welcome to the real world yeah i wonder
where all that money is going to go
that's what i'm saying i mean i keep
seeing like you you support black lives
matter
you're just supporting democrats right
exactly it's the same
same so did we talk about the ashanti
cloth thing the democrats did
yeah i looked it up it's true i i know i
said
yeah so okay okay it's the democrats
uh they wore these claws they're called
kente claws
and it turns out the ones they wore
specifically came from the ashanti
empire which made a fortune dealing in
slavery with the british empire
yep selling off their own people what do
you think they did that's amazing
they were like they had no idea no no
that was that was a virtue signal
somebody had that's all it was no
somebody listen so you think
someone was like oh man this is gonna be
great they're gonna wear these and make
fools of themselves
like they had no idea what they were
1990
in 1994 a magic the gathering card was
made
and what is that what is your cat that
is yelling
anyway magic the gathering card was made
and apparently the the artist i guess
they're saying was racist
and then it got data based under 1488
somebody knew
exactly what they were doing when they
did that they thought it was funny right
so or they were doing it on purpose well
we'll get to this but i'm making a point
right okay because we'll talk
we'll talk about the magic stuff next
somebody got these claws from the
democrats and had to know exactly what
they were and where they were from
definitely these claws were from a
specific tribe that was like
slave traders yep that's true okay
anyway but back to the the capitol hill
free zone yes so the democrats
are basically uh you know supporting
this yep
bowing to it bending the knee to it
although they are going back on the
defund the police thing they're trying
to separate themselves from that and to
be specific i mean the black lives
matter stuff
okay which is exactly what they're you
know saying in this uh so i have this
article right
and it's really funny because if you
look at the pictures everybody everybody
there's white
there's like there's some people who are
not white but this is the article that
was posted i guess and i don't even know
who posted it oh
oh i'm sorry they translated uh uh they
transcribed the actual spoken list of
demands okay
yeah so it says the demands of the
collective black voices at free capital
capitol hill to the government of
seattle washington
i don't want to read too much but i want
to highlight one specific thing where
they say
the uh the first demand the number one
demand the seattle police department and
attached
court system are beyond reform we do not
request reform we demand
abolition we demand the seattle city
council and the mayor defund and
abolish the seattle police department
and the attached criminal justice
apparatus
this means 100 percent of funding
including existing pensions for seattle
police
at an equal level of priority we also
demand that the city disallow the
operations of ice in the city of seattle
you see you give them an inch they take
50 miles
now they want to abolish the courts all
the democrats are trying to walk this
back though
like bernie sanders was like no no we
don't want to bother
and and joe biden just issued a
statement probably from some 20 year old
the works from because he's sleeping
yeah
but what you know i think nancy pelosi's
response was i guess that's a decision
for local jurisdictions
that's the question yeah you're like
you're drafting uh a bill
on police reform right give us an answer
what's your opinion
but she was like local jurisdictions
will take care of it oh yeah i'm
you you will not enjoy living in a city
with no police and i'm gonna show you
why right now
check out uh this tweet i don't know who
this is
presumably some person just down in
seattle okay he said
seattle rapper an alleged sex trafficker
raz assaulted graffiti artists with a
huge group of goons just for tagging
forced them out of the zone followed
them 10 blocks and then one of them
pulled a gun
on them when they tried to defend
themselves wow one of the i'm assuming
it means one of
raz's goons or whatever so on on reddit
somebody was posting about this and they
posted a video where in it you can hear
someone say
we're the police now yeah i saw that
he's like we're the police now like we
have to take care of this place
yeah so apparently though uh the dude
razz they were mad because the tagger
was taking up a building that people
lived in
and they were like we got to keep this
clean and safe yeah you heard him say
like did you did you talk to the owner
of this building
right you know the owner of this
building is allowing us to be here like
we gotta we gotta give respect to
you know to the the building owner like
oh
that's pretty legit like all right okay
and then the guy's like
f off you can't tell what to do yeah
yeah welcome to anarchy dude i'm tagging
you right but think think about the how
hilarious that is that's just the
beginning
you you think it sounds cool that razz
was like hey the business
the guy who owns this building you know
he's letting us be here do you think
that was
that was a cool thing well i wouldn't
say cool no
but it's it's a step in the right
direction
i guess i think it's a perfect example
of what these people really want
they want the same power for themselves
good point so they talk about how
you know we got to abolish this abolish
that and the bourgeoisie or whatever but
as soon as they get power they're like
don't worry we'll protect the business
owners
we'll protect the rich property owners
we won't allow you
a poor person to ride on this building
because the property owner doesn't want
it
now i got i got no problem with the
property owner saying don't tag my
building it's not like what mobsters
would do
exactly like you're under our protection
now don't don't you worry as long as you
pay up
500 bucks that's what the business owner
is here here's the point
this guy says you know this this
autonomous thing is all about
commune and freedom the moment they're
handed the reins
they go doing the exact same thing they
accuse the police of doing
they protect the land owners look
look if you own property you people
don't have a right to destroy it
okay um and there there are certain i'm
probably i don't i want to be absolute
on this like depending what the property
is
if you're like you know infringing on
someone else's rights in some capacity
but the point is this dude is just
trying to gain the power of the police
and that's why his goons were like we're
the police now
that's their real complaint it's like i
was saying dude during occupy wall
street when they told me about flipping
the pyramid
they're like we want to flip the pyramid
over and a dumb person goes then all of
the poor people will be on top
that's impossible you can't just make
poor people rich
and in power it doesn't work that way
right no what happens is
the pyramid crumbles into a pile and now
it's a destroyed dilapidated
pile of bricks but at least those people
are on top now because they flipped it
you know what i mean
sure that's what it is get rid of the
police they say abolish the police
look at me we are the police now that's
literally what they did
they're they're right now saying we want
to abolish the police yeah and
as soon as they take a space and the
police are gone they assume all that
power
yep and they do the same thing the
police did they just want the reins man
that's it
so i got this tweet thread from jake
hanrahan now jake
jake's a real journalist okay jake has
actually covered
like and gone on the ground and dealt
with like real extremists and real
revolutionaries
that's why i think his threat is
particular particularly hilarious
because what do you think his opinion is
going to be having actually covered real
far right groups with guns doing
military training in eastern europe
and actually dealing with revolutionary
anarchists and things like that
i have no idea what you you think when
he goes down to this little antifa thing
how do you think he's going to feel
about it i
expect to get a lot of giggles
he makes fun of him yeah i'm not
surprised look at this
so hold on hold on where's he uh he
posted a picture quote regime encampment
oh my god get real
larping as if it's syria he says if the
regime thing is a joke then fair play
that's funny seems like a lot of
so-called radicals are getting very
upset about what a journalist has to say
on twitter though
i just think you make yourselves look
silly when you exaggerate a situation
like calling this an autonomous zone
yeah it'd be very cool if it was the
beginning of one though
and good luck to you i hope it is okay
this is beginning to look
more like it left liberty uh left
libertarian movement
john brown gun club turned up armed to
do patrols
now i don't know much about the john
brown gun club
in terms of what their goals are okay
but i really don't like when people
confuse
antifa and anti-affiliated groups with
left libertarian
so this may be left libertarian perhaps
like just because these guys are armed
and walking around i'm not going to
assume they're violent authoritarians
who want to impose their will on others
i know a lot of these guys i've seen uh
i'm not sure which group it was
there was a it's a far left communist
armed patrol like armed militia okay
but if you watch the videos they're very
disciplined they're very calm and they
try to keep the peace
they don't they don't sit there and
allow people to go nuts a lot of people
don't like it
but look man if they're legally allowed
to do it they're non-violent
and they're trying to keep tensions down
totally fine with it that goes for the
the oath keepers the three percenters
anybody else
i don't care what your ideology is so
long as we can live peacefully
have some real conversations so if the
john brown gun club shows up they're
armed they're doing their thing and
they're peacefully you know
walking around and making sure people
don't act a fool that's cool that's fine
by me
i don't care the grid you know it's the
it's the crazy ones
again the john brown gun club had this
guy
who was an about antifa who went and
firebombed an ice facility
that's why i'm like we haven't seen the
oath keepers do something like that
okay so i'm not i'm not trying to just
you know pass off what these what these
people have done
but you know be that as it may
i'm not going to pretend like someone
marching with a gun is like the world is
ending
and that being said too i don't know if
you saw the project veritas videos they
did
the uh project veritas part of these
videos of antifa doing like gun strength
filtration yeah yeah and and i think
it's interesting to see that antifa they
are an ideological extremist group
they've talked about doing crazy things
they've talked about
burning the system down and destroying
civilization you see them doing military
training i think it's it's valuable to
see that they actually have organized
training
however the act in and of itself of
doing firearms training and survival
training and self-defense training
i got no problem with just just because
they're doing that i'm like
no the issue is if they use that
training
here's what i see if these people like
the john brown gun club go and engage in
some kind of act of terror
then you need to consider what their
group is what they do how they train
yeah and then maybe there's some trumped
up charges or something
so there was there was apparently like a
live stream of this here's what he says
jake says the more i hear about this
autonomous zone only on only day two
the more it seems doomed to fail seeing
that a load of woke scolds are there
desperate for power by policing people
also the armed contingent is smaller
than uh than i thought
and seemingly unprepared for actual
defense let alone they run out of food
already today you saw that tweet right
well she was saying that someone stole
their the homeless people stole all
their food
no they said they took the food yeah but
they invited them in
what do you think they're gonna do
they're homeless people you're giving
out free food they're gonna eat the food
they're gonna take your food dude yeah
they're gonna eat it and then and then
what did she ask for
vegan options vegan options meat no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
toots soy
based food i was about
i was like cringing i i was just i was
like that is peak privilege right there
yeah we talked about it it's like being
a vegan
you're in a privileged place to be able
to greatly be able to eat vegan and
be comfortable and and healthy at the
same time but
not just that like good vegan options
are hard to come by yeah so to ask
someone to go out of their way
they're fine it's not cheap right no but
here's the funny part
it's one thing if you said we have we
have vegans here and so we'll you know
just keep that in mind
yeah veggies potatoes yeah yeah those
are cheap whatever fruits
no she asked for like the high quality
vegan meat substitutes
alternatives talk about the one percent
these people dude
i couldn't stop laughing when i saw that
like
you are the reason you're giving vegans
a bad name
you know it's a wealthy enough place and
this young white woman
has probably gotten her parents she goes
i don't want to eat meat because i
believe in fighting for justice so her
parents were like whatever you stayed
here and then went to the store and
bought her the expensive vegan options
and now she wants them and now she's
occupying and she's like bring me the
expensive options from the health food
store
nothing from walmart please well walmart
actually has some pretty good vegan
options mind you actually they do
they sell chow cheese yes but they got a
lot they got a lot of other stuff too
surprisingly
and if you're watching this field life
you can uh feel like
no feel field roast feel free to sponsor
me
[Laughter]
my favorite i got this guy to be in love
with chow choose yeah it's
good it's great it's really good i like
i make pizzas with it i put pepperoni on
it just to spit in the in the
in the oh man well i still giggle when i
when i think about that tweet man that
she wanted yes
that is it is just brings joy i don't
know why i'm satisfied
because it's it's proof that they're
just privileged people
they're white and kids you like said it
you know it's no that's like
what could i imagine it's like there's a
kid there's like a seven-year-old kid in
his backyard playing like cowboys and
indians or whatever yeah
and then he's like mom can you make
peanut butter and jelly but i don't want
any crust because the crusts don't taste
good
and then the other kid's like oh see if
she'll get the barbecue chips those are
good mom
can you get the barbecue barbecue chips
and then she comes out and she's got
like
she's got like salt and vinegar mom i
wanted barbecue
why are you ah this is salt and vinegar
mom
and then she's like okay okay it's like
cartman oh my god south park
she brings the hot pot hot pockets to
him mm-hmm all right let's keep reading
i love this thread from jakey says
people are mad i'm so pessimistic about
it but this comes after years of seeing
radical u.s leftist spaces destroy and
warp the very idea of leftism
i'm not hopeful that the so-called az
will ever actually become one
for what it's worth i've been to several
actual autonomous zones
he says check this where is the internal
security if you can't autonomously
defend the zone then it isn't an
autonomous zone and then he referenced
the
the guy yeah here we go
just saw some stuff about the capitol
hill autonomous zone to summarize
woke scolders are drunk on power
policing people's language
radical liberals told the armed leftists
to leave and now a local rapper is
acting as a one-day warlord beating of
activists
two days two days two days
oh when the homeless oh and the homeless
people they invited
stole all the food yeah oh my gosh
yeah well what do you expect you know
what man they they're
they know how to live on the streets
seriously food being offered you take it
yep no because the homeless people know
what hardship really is
yeah and they're probably thinking like
these kids are so dumb yeah let's just
take the things
dude yeah we're going to go back to our
imagining a homeless guy walking up
and there's there's like some uh gluten
seitan
like you know hot dog and he's like what
is this yeah and they're like it's a
meatless
a vegan alternative that was delivered
that's what we asked for well the beyond
sausage is actually pretty legit no i
just mean like they're going to be like
what is this i don't know what this food
is they don't want this
this is great well they clearly ate it
all they didn't mind
hold on he says uh this is what happens
when you allow the professionally
offended to overrun the left and destroy
it with extreme identity politics wow
it's not nice or popular to say but the
reality is you can't run an autonomous
zone if you let absolute cowards
constantly have their say
wow yes that is what i'm talking about
standing ovation
offended that is that sums it up perfect
yeah that's it
yeah wow he says not to get too
political but i actually think genuine
autonomous zones are exciting and
worthwhile alternative to
hyper-capitalist wage slave hell world
i just don't think the people who took
part in this one knew what they were
doing at all
he says getting manhandled for spraying
graffiti they went from an arco
syndicalist commune to the ussr in two
days
oh man bravo uh he's got more to be fair
though there's a
there's a lot of good uh stuff going on
in the chas too from what i understand
we'll be doing some kind of report about
that side of
uh side of it for popular front co i
just wish someone had told them to calm
down at the start
so uh if you're not familiar with jake
check him out he runs popular front it's
a pretty cool thing he does like he has
real journalism he's actually documented
like
right wing like uh right-wing
militaristic groups
whatever i you know check him out on
youtube school dude
but uh i do think that there's a there's
a funny thing you can learn
about anarchist society so
there's left and right-wing anarchy you
know so i know some right-wing
anarchists okay
they're like the true definition of
anarchist okay and the root of anarchy
is without authority
so the right-wing anarchists are
basically like do your thing
you know buy or be aware let the market
decide just don't don't attack other
people like you can't
violate someone else's rights like you
can't assert your authority over them
still very libertarian though well
libertarian is one step above
okay libertarian is right right so so on
the political compass
anarchy is as low as you can go okay
then you have left and you have right
the right is the true anarchist now the
left will argue that's the truth they're
true because capitalism is oppressive
now shut up right wing
anarchy is literally like you're in the
middle of the woods you're on your own
left-wing anarchy is utopianist we all
hold hands and sing songs together and
build a happy farm where everyone gets
you know equal shares of things
with replicators that produce everything
right right without work
left-wing left-wing anarchy like the far
left is possible
in a tiny tiny group tiny tiny group you
can't get really big with it
right-wing anarchy is possible with a
very very very large group
but it can devolve into monopolistic
empire
and oppressive you know black operations
type security
so you know the way i usually describe
it to people about like
the best government you could you'd ever
want is probably in the right
libertarian spectrum
because within that you can have your
left libertarian
society you know it it doesn't operate
in the inverse in the utopianist ideals
you can't have you know yeah but so so
anyway
when you see this i often i try to
explain to my anarchist friends like the
lefty anarchist ones why they'll never
have a large civilization
a large country or anything be anarchist
and they like to reference
like uh um catalonia and it's like the
brief anarchist period
or whatever they had what is catalonia
it's part of spain
like where barcelona is up okay and so
they had a brief period where
it was anarchist there was no formal
government it kind of just operated and
they're like that proves it and i'm like
and what happened to it
it got taken over yeah that's the point
you have no
like like jake mentioned you you have no
autonomous defense
yeah so just chaos breaks and here two
days later we already got like a warlord
right happening boom there it is taking
control yep exactly
yeah because in in this utopian ideal
they have
nobody takes can like there's no
authority because no one tries to assert
it
so you have a bunch of people sitting
around saying hey don't leave me alone i
don't know
then when a warlord shows up people are
like oh man don't look don't look at me
i don't know
and then the warlord takes over and
they're like yeah whatever you say and
then he walks in your business give me
your money and you're like you got a bus
yep and there you go the easier the
easiest way to explain it though if i
went back to like
uh historical times or not historical
times like ancient
think of it this way let's say you got a
thousand people okay and they form their
anarcho hippie commune or whatever
and they're all sitting around trying to
decide what is the right way
i've i've seen these things like occupy
wall street where
one person you know will raise their
hand and then someone will be like what
do you have to say and they'll say i say
we propose this
and then everybody will like wiggle
their fingers if they agree if they
agree
or they'll do an x with their hands and
they disagree and it's like
three four hours go by and no decision
has been made on anything
let me tell you a story man this is
hilarious during occupy wall street
which is very similar to what we're
seeing here yeah we needed
uh or the occupation needed bins to keep
clothes dry
okay yeah so when it rains people get
wet you get sick and so they were like
people who have backpacks and extra
clothes we should get plastic bins and
keep them dry in the rain
so somebody proposed we buy bins and
then they were like okay
all in favor of buying plastic bins for
clothes
and then we got a couple of these x's no
no we we borrow it
we we block it and they were like okay
why do you block it
one person says i am okay with it only
if the bins are recycled
because we don't want to support you
know
plastic and they were like okay all in
favor of buying
recycled plastic bins people do their
little twinkle fingers
and then block someone goes it needs to
be fair trade
we can't have people indigenous peoples
being exploited for the production and
they were like
okay where do you find plastic that are
recycled and fair trade i don't even
think that's a thing does that exist
here's can you guess what ended up
happening they they didn't get bins they
did oh they did yeah oh i can guess what
they didn't have guess that can you
guess what they did
bought regular they bought regular plain
old bins non-recyclable yep
regular they went to like the the local
store and just came back with bins and
they were like yeah they're fair trade
recycled yeah sure we
investigated and it's good yup don't
worry don't ask
and and and get and you think anybody
did no
of course not no of course not so this
is the problem they're just trying to
to signal to everyone how virtuous they
are create the appearance
so imagine now you're you're your
thousand people are in the fields of uh
i don't know western europe in the year
1000
okay and you're all your little hippie
friends are sitting around and you're
like
what do we do for food and then after a
few hours you finally figure it out
congratulations
right if you're eating something it's
right something happened but then all of
a sudden
someone comes running full speed they're
sweating they're out of breath and they
go
the evil warlord zorlon is heading this
way
with with a thousand men and and fifty
horses and
and bow and arrows what do we do and
they go
i propose we form a phalanx no i block
four hours go by and they're arguing and
then the dude runs in on his horse and
just starts to beheading everybody and
then he steals all the women in the food
and then your civilization is gone
to put it simply while you're bickering
about how to handle things
the warlord comes in and just takes it
yeah and that's what happened in two
days
two days in the seattle autonomous the
capitol hill autonomous zone
they've already got a warlord going
around threatening people defending the
the building owners yeah it's amazing
it's amazing it really is yeah and so
uh i think i i think this is why i
really sorry i just got to say
everyone in chat is hailing sorlan now
zorlon
hail zorlan love you chad the barbarian
leader
conqueror of worlds
let's do this let's give him a back
story it's actually the year is actually
25
53 and human civilization was purged in
a great war and it collapsed
so now it's the future and a bunch of
people discover the ancient text
the antifa handbook and they decide to
live this way oh no
and then zorolon finds a bunch of
fascistic you know literature and
genghis khan history and alexander the
great and is like
yeah take what's mine i'm going to take
what's mine
i am lord zolon and now the world is his
oh that's great thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you